Matt Walsh who was increasingly known as  an anti-trans guy now during an event  um where he took audience questions said  he thinks that genetically modified food  GMOs could be partly to blame for the  existence of trans people there is of  course absolutely no evidence for this  whatsoever you know the topic of GMO is  interesting there are many on the left  who are against GMOs and I believe that  at one point I also reflexively just  kind of assumed they must be bad because  I'm hearing that they are they're  actually not and there is not actually  evidence that eating genetically  modified food is bad for you now the  question of pesticides often used on  GMOs is a different one pesticides  different story I would love it if more  people on the left actually understood  the science of GMO and in the meantime  this guy on the right Matt Walsh is  saying I don't know maybe GMO foods are  responsible for transgenderism  irresponsible and absolutely absurd